mademoiselle sophie joissains pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame dominique
bertinotti ministre chargée de la
famille rééquilibrer les comptes publics
n'est certes pas chose facile
et en la matière les valeurs de l'état
s'exprime aussi par la priorité qu'il
donne aux mesures qu'il met en place
certains domaines comme les avantages
des retraités ou les actions concernant
la politique familiale surtout dans le
temps de crise que nous traversons ne
pourront manquer d'être interprétée sur
un plan symbolique et idéologiques les
gouvernements précédents y ont été
confrontés et encore une fois la crise
ne pourra qu'accentuer qu'amplifier le
sens de toute mesure prise sur ces
secteurs
l'image du couple riche dénué de
préoccupations matérielles touchant des
allocations confronté à celui peinant
pour nourrir ses enfants pourraient
influer dans le sens des mesures sur les
allocations familiales préconisé par le
président de la cour des comptes
mais cette image est une image d'epinal
seule la classe moyenne celle que nous
devons conforter mobiliser revitaliser
subira réellement cette diminution des
allocations familiales
les allocations familiales ne sont pas
un outil de répartition et de justice
sociale
il s'agit à ça j'ai à salaire égal de
favoriser les couples qui décident de
faire des enfants
la genèse un état est une condition ou à
paramètre essentiel à tout développement
et en ce sens ces allocations familiales
constituent un investissement sûr
l'avenir
de plus l'état en maintenant le principe
d'universalité préserve un lien
politique incitatif et protecteur avec
l'ensemble des familles françaises
toucher aux allocations familiales c'est
prendre le risque de modifier le contrat
social dans le partage par tous les
français est crucial dans la période que
nous traversons accroître le clivage
entre les français paraît aujourd'hui
bien dangereux et bien risqué ceci
d'autant plus que nous pourrions en
amont de ce type de mesures
revisiter certains postes de la dépense
publique pouvez vous madame le ministre
nous indiquer si le gouvernement
maintient cette piste de rééquilibrage
budget
r et si tel est le cas quelle est la
forme de diminution des allocations
familiales qu'ils privilégient
l'intégration de leurs montants à
l'impôt c'est à dire oui la hausse des
prélèvements
ou bien leurs attributions sous
conditions de ressources ce qui battrait
évidemment en brèche le principe
d'universalité de la politique familiale
merci madame dominique bertinotti
ministre chargée de la famille
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice je voudrais quand même
rappeler un certain nombre de réalités
qui témoigne de la pertinence du
questionnement du gouvernement sur cette
question comment on pourrait aujourd'hui
refuser de se questionner alors que
c'est sous le précédent gouvernement que
la branche famille
eh oui que la branche famille qui
n'était pas déficitaire les deux venus
au fur et à mesure des années qui se
sont écoulées sous le quinquennat
précédent passant d'un déficit de 300
millions d'euros en 2008 un déficit de
2,6 milliards en 2011
comment expliquer comment ne pas se
questionner lorsque c'est vous qui avez
sous indexer des prestations familiales
provoquant une perte de pouvoir d'achat
de l'ensemble de ces familles de l'ordre
de 601 millions d'euros comment
s'interdirait ton de se questionner
alors qu'avec 3,7 pour cent du produit
intérieur brut qui est affectée aux
allocations familiales et aux
allégements d'impôts la france est
certes en tête des pays européens en ce
qui concerne les dépenses en faveur de
la famille mais bien loin d'être en tête
en ce qui concerne la lutte contre la
pauvreté des enfants comme l'a rappelé
très cruellement rapport récent de
l'unicef
comment refuser de se questionner alors
que les attentes et les besoins des
familles ont évolué et une là aussi une
analyse du credoc leur rappelle 69 % des
parents considèrent aujourd'hui
préférable pour mieux aider les familles
de leur fournir
z sous forme d'équipements et de
services contre 30% qui optent pour des
prestations financières
comment refuser de se questionner alors
que les sondages récents montrent que
les français eux mêmes sont prêts à
envisager des évolutions dans notre
système
alors effectivement vous voyez la
pertinence que le premier ministre a eu
de saisir bertrand fragonard président
du haut conseil à la famille d'une
mission globale sur les aides aux
familles
il lui a été demandé à partir des aides
existantes d'établir une cartographie et
et cet exercice devra déboucher sur des
propositions cohérentes d'évolution car
il est légitime de se questionner sur
l'économie générale du système d' aide
aux familles architecture d'ensemble
efficience des dispositifs pertinence de
leur ciblage
il est légitime de rechercher une
combinaison mieux adapté aux besoins
actuels entre les aides financières plus
redistributive et le développement des
services comme les modes d'accueil des
enfants et de soutien aux parents alors
vous vous pensez que l'immuabilité est
un gage d'avenir
eh bien nous nous pensons que la justice
et l'équité l'égalité est le véritable
gage d'avenir
merci